we never sort of looked at ourselves as
a startup or we're building a startup
it was more like we're building this you
know platform that has a ton of value to
people like me
in my mind that i think could be really
cool and people will really enjoy using
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
this one is all about
filmmaking but in a different way meet
ira belski the co-founder and co-ceo of
artless
ltd era is a self-taught filmmaker who
in 2016 co-founded the music licensing
platform art list
together with three friends as the
company's co-ceo
era helped develop artless into a leader
in the creative stock licensing industry
in 2019 the company launched the stock
footage site art grid
and in 2020 they released a new sound
effects library and purchased the
creative asset marketplace
motion array for 65 million dollars
today
artlist is the go-to licensing provider
for content creators in over 160
countries
ira belski thank you for joining me on
20 milliliters how are you
i'm great how are you i'm good are you
calling from the kibbutz right now or
where are you in israel
no um left left the kibbutz like um
hour and a half ago to come to tel aviv
help
sort of building our tel aviv
office but in heart i'm still in the
north
well i i definitely heard because i
think that that really is a theme that i
want to
to touch on because i think that your
founding story of art lists a
company that i believe you've raised
over 60 million dollars for your
creators platform right to provide a
different content for different creators
whether it's music or film or
etc you're a filmmaker by profession and
but really the company was founded in
kibbutz and and you mentioned that your
family you know their main profession is
farming mangoes in a moshav in the north
of israel right
yes so i'm coming from a farm
farming uh family uh in the north of
israel
um growing uh you know from grapefruits
to mangoes and everything in between so
um yeah a bit of a you know
um not the most typical place
to grow up starting uh building a
startup so
tell me a little bit about your about
your upbringing because
from what it sounds like from an
outsider it wasn't that obvious that
you're going to go into
the startup scene right you go and you
study filmmaking and
how do you even you know take that and
position yourself
then as you know an entrepreneur let
alone one that is going to raise
more than 60 million dollars to make a
really big dent in this market
yeah so hey i didn't even
study filming i was self-taught
for that as well and to be honest i
haven't
i never really started a career in like
entrepreneurship or startup it sort of
happened
without even knowing you know i'm in
this space so
i think it really came down to sort of
the
[Applause]
the very you know i think common
uh way you start a startup which is you
know
a pain you have something you want to
change on your day-to-day
you know uh workflow or whatever
so for me it was like finding music and
footage
uh when i was creating videos so never
intended or even i think
till the site launched and when we
started even a few months later
we never sort of looked at ourselves as
a startup or we're building a startup
it was more like we're building this you
know platform that has a ton of value to
people like me
in my mind that i think could be really
cool and people will really enjoy using
and sort of understood we're sort of in
this startup space later on
right so you're you're understanding
you're in the startup space and can you
talk to me a little bit about this pain
that you talk about so you're you're
saying that you know obviously it all
starts with a pain point you realize
okay there's this gap in the market
i'm experiencing this pain i can
extrapolate that perhaps a lot of others
are experiencing this pain
what is the you know the content
creation market
that we're talking about and what did
you what was the real pain that you
realized that you said okay maybe
there's something here that i could work
on
so back then you had an industry this
sort of
was built for the more enterprise side
of video because
if you're going back like 10 15 years
you didn't really have like a
sort of in the creative space because
youtube wasn't really around
tiktok obviously wasn't right facebook
wasn't around so there was no real place
to distribute your content that if
you're not
putting it on tv and cinema which was
very limited of course so
back then this is sort of the market
shift like when we started and you
started to see like this
huge number of people starting to create
video and
me included and and then sort of
you have tools that were built for
enterprises
um and most of the tool that was
starting to emerge full
small indie content creators were really
pulling my mind so
you either had like very low quality
music or
the legal sort of terms were really
complicated and it was hard to
understand for people that are not
coming from you know they're not an
enterprise you don't have a legal team
backing you up can that can sort of tell
you you know you can use this
there here and this there so in my mind
you know
if we could bridge that gap and sort of
bring extremely high quality content
with very very simple user intuitive
license in a sort of subscription model
that is very
affordable or you know accessible for
more people
we felt like that was a real sort of
pain point we were gonna
solve for a ton of new emerging creators
so that was sort of the space when we
decided to do what we did so era what i
wanted to
to touch on is that what you're saying
is
the film industry from mine saying you
know i grew up to a world where
every person is a content creator every
person wants to create
for example what we're doing in this
show and it's very democratized it's
very easy right
i mean we hop on this platform i i i get
a chance to have a fun conversation with
you
a little bit of you know a video editing
very very simple and i upload it to
facebook and i'm a content creator but
but it wasn't like that before and what
you're saying is that there's this gap
that content creators like myself and
like all my friends
pretty much every person you know today
as a content creator are
need don't have the capacity to go and
create everything original right we want
to start leveraging things that
other users have created and
democratized is there
a is there a dissonance between
originality
and using what somebody else has has
created and
sharing that creation with a lot of
others because obviously the things that
i'm using for my
from my you know product are also being
used for other products
through this idea right yeah
so i think eventually when you look at
video creator
creation it's a collaboration
no matter how you look at it like
at the end of the day like the end goal
that most people strive for is you have
someone writing the script for you
someone you know directing the
camera someone directing the actors
actors um
everything comes together at the end
someone editing the video
music so it's a sort of a collaborative
space it's true that the new youtubers
sort of create a space is more
individual but it doesn't mean that
the process as a whole doesn't really
you know at the end of the day music
and other things sort of collaboration
really elevates video product
projects uh i think in most creators of
something that they're looking for while
creating so
yeah you could say you know someone else
use this
music as well so i'm less original but
yeah you know the
the reality is that what you made with
it sort of the collaboration
and the new sort of meaning you brought
into that
piece of content is yours and that's
sort of
where the originality comes from so you
can look at tik-tok well people use the
same
sound like millions of times and each of
them
makes it their own and that's the point
of the platform like reusing something
and
building yourself on it so i think that
just
takes this essence of co-creation and
taking something and
elevating it to your tell your story
sort of that's
you know where music and video come
together one hundred percent so ira
take me back to the keyboards and tell
me i'd love to hear the founding story
of artless so before
soon we'll get to the actual product and
how you're growing and some of the
you know the insights you've gained from
the industry but i love hearing those
founders stories because it doesn't just
happen overnight it doesn't
it's not that you know you find that you
take it you know cinderella's story
where
you know automatically just works right
there's always some some interesting
background over there so
so tell me a little bit of how you
created art list with your friends
so back at i don't remember if it was
like
beginning of 2015 or something like that
i i
um i drove with a good friend was
extremely talented musicians a musician
um
you know produced like platinum gold
records here in israel
um and i had this thought like let you
know maybe we can sort of i have this
idea i can solve and i
like pitched it to him and he was like
look i don't really understand it
but i sort of trust you so i'm in like
like i'll understand later
and then we had another friend um the
first
person is one of our co-founders asi and
um
and then we we collaborated with another
friend that worked
with us at the time which i introduced
uh called ayal and they were both
extremely talented musicians because i
said okay if we're going to build this
thing
you know we need music right
for someone to help in the sort of tech
space and i had this good friend dizzy
who i knew from the army serving in the
army together
who was a ux developer uh sort of
before i really knew sort of the
difference between those things but
uh working in melanox um so he
joined and we worked on this for like a
year and a half you know while keeping
our other jobs
you know everybody was finishing sort of
what they were doing we would get around
meet up amazing welcome this thing
um you know i see and they are producing
music me and it's equal sort of
building and designing the website hired
a few you know developers from fiverr
and other places
just hassling it with our own money and
ourselves
and then so era this we sort of beg your
question
why why go and why
do this you know at night when it's
difficult in a weekend when you don't
have time why not just everybody quit
your day jobs
and just go all in on this why why do
that you know
that do both at the same time
yeah you know for me it was easier
because i was freelancing at the time
and i didn't have a family to support
you know now i have a baby girl and
and it's a different mindset but for
example
assy had four kids back then already um
yitzik had a day job at mellanox
so it was a bit harder for them so
you know you need to make a living and
you need to
sort of weigh in your risk and capable
um
but i think when we launched it was like
extremely apparent to all of us that
we're gonna
do this full-time very quickly so uh
but uh yeah so we sort of built this
thing offline
for a year and a half one of the really
really good advantages we had
because i think one of the hardest thing
is like advertising when you don't have
a budget
um we were really disruptive in a space
where
people really wanted good products the
video
space and me coming from that space i
was like you know what where
would i want to read about this new
product if if it was launched
so we just kept in very good connection
with like blogs and influencers in the
field sort of
building them to be sort of beta testers
and and giving their users like free
and like free songs before so by the
time we've launched we actually got
pretty good exposure and and you know
there's this story that uh
we always tell that you know itzik was
building the paypal and everything like
that with the team and
he said you know a day before we were
set to launch i'll just
put the site live and check you know the
payment process that it actually works
and when you put it live like the same
minute before he was able to
to test the payment process someone
bought the subscription
you know and we were like wow you know
we weren't expecting people actually
refreshing and going to the site
so that was crazy and and
and i think yeah you know um then we
launched it and everything was really
hectic you know this then we start a
journey of five years
still trying to understand where we are
and that's that's unbelievable so
obviously you know five years later
you're at
a phenomenal marketplace for content
creators you like i mentioned you raised
more than 65 million dollars from top
investors
both in israel and in the us and and
you're growing incredibly
tell me a little bit about how you
learned you know obviously you learned
about all the things you have to do as
an entrepreneur
you know with two bare hands right they
didn't go study entrepreneurship
or didn't you know mba and
entrepreneurship
but you actually learned by doing so
what are some of the most you know
surprising things that you encounter and
you're like huh like okay i like i
wonder like what do i do now like
like whether it's like in the pricing or
in the hiring or in the firing
i'm always curious to hear about how do
you actually turn you know this lack of
experience
into excitement and passion to learn
through mistakes and through doing
wow it's an amazing question
and i have to say you know it's
really really interesting because you
come into this and you're starting off
you're building a product
and then you're like okay now i need to
sort of build a team
and then you right now i need to build a
company and a company needs culture
it needs sort of hiring process it is
someone taking over you know product
development how do i make processes that
make the organization work i always say
like i feel
that every quota you need to learn
a new sort of a skill
not even a skill or actually learning a
new profession like i feel like
every quarter i'm a different type i
mean i'm in a different type of
profession
and it's it's that drastic like looking
back a year ago
i did something completely different
than when i'm focused on
completely different things and every
time i look back like it was like
180 degrees different than what i was
actually focusing on and like you said
you know you start with product and you
have very simple understanding of the
product
and then you start going deeper into
sort of how
how people should manage people and then
how people should hire people and how do
you make processes
work and how do you make processes work
but
in the same time you're sort of getting
deeper into understanding product
users data bi you know things that you
weren't
really focused on starting off you were
like okay it's work
it's working i really know because i
built it
but right now like you know i have tens
of people working on the product
and what's happening with it how do i
track it what's going on how do we
improve now
so it's it's a journey look i i i don't
know if if you can
learn it anywhere it's it's it's
you know making a good company and not a
good product or a good idea it's
just making a ton of good decisions
small good decisions along the way
there's no
one plan that you like i plan this
really good or better than someone else
it's like you just have to make good
you know on the spot decisions
and make and build team that can do the
same so
yeah what did you learn about the music
and content creation industry
that perhaps surprised you that you know
you said okay you know i
as you know a self-taught filmmaker
thought one thing but now i'm actually
seeing a different consumer behavior
that
i didn't necessarily expect but i'm you
know adapting to it with art list
so what what what insights do you have
from the industry now
um i think first of all we're in
two different industries so we have the
supply and the demand side
um on the music side we have you know a
strong connection to the music industry
all other sort of fronts were in the
video space
user-wise and in the footage and
templates and other things
so um the music space
is changing in one way and the video
space is changing in a whole completely
other way so first of all in the video
space
you know coming into this i was we were
really focused on people
earning money and making producing
professional videos for clients
and learning you know what makes
youtubers create content for example
which is a completely different mindset
you know they're creating content to
sort of express themselves
to tell their story to build a brand
around themselves
right and not around client work
which is completely different because
for example if you look at it when we
look to and will still look and working
on personality
personalizing the experience if you look
at someone producing
um projects for clients then you're like
how do i personalize that because they
can have a client which is you know
manufactured toys for kids and then
they're
doing a gym commercial for like you know
extreme rock
work where well the connection sort of
personally comes
but when you look at youtubers it's
really a reflection of their identity
and it's a lot more similar to the sort
of the conventional personalization
experience that we're used to
you know this is what i like this is how
i express myself so
this is something that we're always
learning and trying to figure out
sort of the difference between client
work
and someone creating content to tell
their story and
sort of express their identity and so
that's on the video side which is always
interesting
on the music side you have an industry
that is
completely evolving right now and
reinventing itself
so you're coming from the 90s well there
was
a ton of money in the industry but you
know
the big labels and record labels got the
name of like you know stealing from
artists and you had all these laws
built in order to protect musicians and
now you come to
today well these laws actually sometimes
harm musicians
because it doesn't allow them the
freedom
to work professionally with their music
sometimes and and it's challenging
and the process of licensing and youtube
are very new
to the music industry the the industry
wasn't built for this
in the 90s so they were sort of
re-evaluating everything
will somewhere like exactly in the
middle of all of this happening
trying to work out and collaborate with
different pros and and
and you know with youtube and other sort
of online platforms
um but i think it's also the best you
know we're looking at the past
two years that well the first years that
the music industry was actually on the
rise and not on the down
fall in terms of like earnings and
revenue
so um and we're happy to be a part of
that like we'll
pay millions of millions of dollars a
year for musicians
and we're extremely proud amazing to be
on the side that actually brings money
back
to this space uh for real relationships
um so it's really exciting to be a part
of this evolution
that's uh that's really really
incredible i think that you know this
idea of the marketplace where you're
actually
you know empowering content you're
empowering these new content creators
with original content creators and
you're
you know creating this revenue sharing
model that that really makes a
you know a two-sided incentive market
which is phenomenal
and it works and obviously you know your
growth just shows how much it works and
i love
i know i love your perception into
growing with the company and growing
with hands-on learning i think that's
truly inspiring era thank you for taking
the time to be here
i really appreciate it i have the most
important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
yeah the hardest one the hardest one
i would definitely say reasonable
i hope i'm right by saying humble um
and um i guess creative
you know coming from the creation
reasonable humble creative
no yeah now being a manager
still trying to be creative first
thank you very very much i'll let you
get back to work but i really appreciate
you coming here
and stay safe and stay healthy
likewise thanks a lot